[Música]
imagínense la siguiente situación se
juntan con un amigo al conocer hace ya
34 años en el verano ese momento del año
para juntarse con amigos sin excusa
alguna más que verse y charlar
caminan por un parque ver un espectáculo
de la gorra
se ponen al día su amigo en una sacas y
expedía les dices te veo feliz
si un amigo alguien que te quiere que te
vive acompañado atravesando un montón de
momentos te dice eso es lo que antes ese
te veo feliz oculta algo un antes un
momento en el que no me vio feliz
y tenía razón
un año antes terminando quinto año me
fui dos meses de intercambio una chica
italiana había vivido en mi casa por dos
meses y ahora era mi turno ahí para allá
roma se convertía en mi mundo por un
tiempito ya conocía roma había ido con
mi mamá hace unos años en este
intercambio pero de sólo unos días lo
que no conocía a la familia con la que
iba a vivir la casa en la que me iba a
quedar el idioma en el cual iba a tener
que hablar ni la escuela era igual iba
terán que le conocía pero no conocía
verdaderamente las cosas entonces iba a
poder reconocer una ciudad de una forma
completamente distinta iba a estar sola
en mi familia y sin mis amigos pero con
mis ideas sí misma ambos
lo que no sabía en ese momento es que va
a conocer más que sólo una ciudad y
aprender más que solo un idioma y
empezar a conocerme a mí
me encanta hablar me sale naturalmente
habla hasta por los codos buenos
silencios acá para espacios hablo el
clima de la facultad de fútbol de
política de recetas y de viajes a un
poco con todos de todos pero nunca de mí
un poco hablo de mí pero nunca en
profundidad de cosas realmente
personales en ese momento las palabras
no me salen hasta no tenía nada para
decir o mejor dicho no podía decirlo no
hablaba el idioma ya no podía llenar
silencios y acaparar espacios estaba
obligada a escuchar
antes y en mi idioma en el apuro de
querer tener la primera y la última
palabra decía lo primero que se me venía
a la cabeza sin pararme a pensar ni
medio segundo en cómo iba a decir lo que
quería decir y eso muchas veces me salía
mal hasta ya no manejaba el idioma yo no
podía manejar de cuáles temas hablar y
de cuáles no
vieron que cuando llegan a un lugar
nuevo siempre tienen que presentarse
toda presentación tiene dos grandes
patas la primera para decir lo que se
tiene pensado decir tener las palabras
para decirlo
los primeros días intercambios no podía
decir más que olas bien si no y chau no
me quedaba otra que escuchar así que me
volví todo a vídeos
debo confesar no mucho por interés en la
que la otra persona me estaba contando
necesitaba escuchar para aprender el
idioma para poder volver a hablar con el
paso de los días algo más suelta
descubre el placer de escuchar al otro
de verdad que no quería apurarme y
avasallar lo de no querer ganar el
protagonismo de la charla viaje del pony
del pedestal de la soberbia para por
primera vez conversar con otro de igual
a igual
tomarte el tiempo para responder te
permite ponerte en el lugar del otro
entender un poco más porque te cuenta lo
que te está contando tomarte el tiempo
para responder te permite también pensar
un poco más en que lo que vos vas a
decir
escuchando ha aprendido un idioma
escuchando aprendí a hablar la primera
pata de poder presentarme estaba
resuelta apoya decir quién era pero
quién era
me paso por la secundaria no fue
particularmente terrible y angustiante
ni mucho menos pero con el diario del
lunes diría que podría haberla pasado un
poco mejor
no estaba muy conforme con quién era
vivía angustiada me preocupaba por todo
lloraba todo el tiempo pero todo el
tiempo
o sea mi límite justo ya lejos de
argentina me había ido de casa pero mis
ideas sí misma ambos habían viajado
conmigo
un día me encontré llorando desconsolada
se imaginan por qué
y esta era mi familia querer compartir
con amigos
no tenéis que esforzarme para hablar
no
lloraba por miedo en enero a 14.000
kilómetros de mi casa porque estaba
segura de que no iba a poder aprobar mi
primer año de facultad
con un poco extraño no tener el miedo al
cambio de nuevo cuando la verdad es que
yo estaba viviendo en una realidad
completamente distinta
el intercambio ya estaba terminando
volver a argentina iba a ser mi
verdadera prueba volver a jugar de local
mi casa mis amigos mi familia mi idioma
pero quería volver a inconformidad a la
soberbia a la angustia a sentir que
nadie me entendía a querer adueñarme de
todos los espacios no eso tenía que
quedarse allá en roma y en el pasado
tenía que volverse un antes
sólo quería comerme al mundo pero no
quería que el mundo me comience a mí
hay una frase que dice la curiosa
paradoja es que cuando me aceptó tal y
como soy entonces puedo cambiar volvamos
a mi amigo
me dijo que me veía feliz
y tenía razón
conocer lugares nuevos personas nuevas
idiomas nuevas experiencias nuevas y
reconocer en el sentido volverá a
conocer lugares personas y cosas de
formas completamente distintas es un
paso previo un puntapié para
reconocernos conocer quiénes somos como
somos nos permite cambiar en definitiva
como dice galliano somos lo que hacemos
para cambiar lo que somos
[Aplausos]
[Música]